- Because there's some employers that say,
you need not apply if you
don't have a college degree.
Am I right, Chris?
- Yeah.
That's been, I think, of
employers, Mike brought this
up in his question to the employer.
We'll just treat a college
degree as, you know,
anti-money.
Like, prove to me you're
serious enough about skills
that you finished college,
and then I'll consider your application.
Not necessarily I'm going
to give you the job.
I just don't even want to
bother interviewing someone
who didn't bother to finish college.
That, of course, misses
the fact there are a lot of
talented people who have good
reasons they didn't finish.
Look, I think we have to
focus more on our skills
than just degrees,
but I also think we'd
be dishonest if we say
when you make a million
dollars more over your lifetime
if you're a four-year
college graduate than not,
this is no time to say to poor kids,
kids of color, first-generation kids,
well, college really isn't for everyone.
So I'm a little bit on the,
yes, skills matter more,
but let's get really worried
about kids who aren't
getting that college opportunity
who need it and want it.